[STUDENT CHATTER]
Annenberg Hall is
where the freshmen eat.
It is the dining
hall, and that is what
it was originally built to do.
It was to be the largest student
dining hall in the late 1870s,
when it first started operation.
But when the houses were
established in the 1930s,
it didn't have a purpose
anymore for many years.
And so it kind of
went into a decline.
It wasn't very
well taken care of.
It's hard for me to believe
that this wonderful building
and that wonderful space
was left almost to disuse.
There's even some thought
in the 1950s of tearing down
Memorial Hall, which seems
incredible to us now, I think.
And that was only reinforced
when the tower caught fire.
And for many years,
Memorial Hall
had no tower until it was
restored in the late 1990s
to the glory that it now
represents on the Cambridge
and Boston skyline.
[STUDENT CHATTER]